l'arrière l'a14 quelques athlètes à
gauche
regardez qu'est à gauche à gauche du
poteau d'écran gauche de l'écran cette
chute est dessus voilà c'est plus la
tête sur tu vois pas dans les camps oui
mon à l'envers l'année gerbes ont alors
redoublé pas de bord manière nous voilà
maintenant on va devant un petit peu tu
pars de laet il est hyper dicateur et tu
vas vers l'eph les traces d'animaux
juste devant eux
d'accord il faut qu'on recule à avoir un
peu d'expérience et voilà c'est pas mal
maintenant de là à partir de là pour te
passe devant eux et tu veux aller devant
deux ans devant nous d'accord du peu ou
pas de retour cela dit il ne surjoue un
peu la peur là c'est marrant tout c'est
quand tu reviens l'argent sur le bruit à
lui déçu
et vas et tu vas dernier devant 2 21
euros sur les traces maintenant qu'ils
tenaient un kit les vins vers les traces
devant le voir là comme ça voilà une
trace de ces très très bon j'ai pas je
suis rêve pas bien des zooms un peu on
fera ça va pas trouvé magnifique de
leurs vaches propos de lumière auquel
est bonne et cotiser à les femmes
parties du corps du comité continue à
squatter très beau tout ça à toi de
vachement beau à regarder mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'écran c'est moins beau c'est
pas vrai c'est vachement beau jeu
parfait c'était super bass et moi de me
wade si ces magnifiques fière de moi je
savais un peu plus haut point hockey
canada